It is a standard, but after all it is not scared Even if the other party is strong, it does not feel scared and it touches
Live towards
That chan angel
Then the word
The strength from the doctor
Ah ah ah
Hmm
nan
Even the students who are putting their lives to defeat
I think there are many
Extensive pain I really do not play
Japan is
After the war
It's a big war
First of all, there is no dispute but it has been reached to this day
When I was in first grade I actually moved and where I went and what I did
I feel like I was not supposed to
It is also becoming an international situation that will not be understood in the future
Probably
Japan in armed clash
I think that there are also things I have to bear in the future
Defensive bar is a simple stick that the attacking side beat the stick
Today's month
The production is about the second week of November
It is held on Sunday, but the meeting is called
The reason why we do it there is just there
An event called the Port Opening Festival will be held at the National Defense University on 20 Saturdays in November.
Ah ah ah
I would like to discuss the fallen cow
South store front strategy
I think that there is certainly a connection the other day
For example, in the process of going to a stupid council
Of course it is analysis and information gathering
Where the SDF and other armed forces are routinely conducted
I took the top of the 8 sticks and I got control
Samon
The name is a position called monkey but
Tatsuya's strong but one-footed applicant controls
Because it was done in three times the time
The feeling of wanting to win is the best
hal
OS-
games
war
Many on the side
Partner It's Volume 1 tax payment teacher
So last year's production was over and we were in the form of runner-up
There were various reasons for not being able to win
How is your partner when you are doing early in the morning
Information first
As much as possible
Forever
Because it is not a wish
ana 2
Border place
On doing
Everyone is really January in the body of fear
I am
me
wh
Yeah yeah yeah
today
Do not have
me
So good nai
Ah ah ah
I think the bottom of the rest is roughly the same
Thank you
I'm doing nails and I'm not doing it at all, and I take 3 checks in the first half and drop it on me
me
Some of the students at the National Defense University are really worried about what they are doing in the future with the Self Defense Force
There may be people who are getting sick of the way the clothes are going, but
Warlord-kun is not personal, though
Please
The men are all
Will be
We won and today a home is born
ni
reirei
Ah ah ah
One
I do not know I was lucky to take 1 a 10th place
Since the beginning of the attack I've been running
One of them was there
It is accompanied by an instruction word and only the attack battle is three dad
I'm receiving
me
Wintering
I was defending, then that time
I was facing the direction of a battalion stick so I could see that one stick fell
Yup
I think I had a pause
What I did was prepare for only two years for you, because this entrance was rewarded
I was very moved by the feeling that was finally rewarded
Thank you
It is interesting to be proud and more proud as a great position student
After all the number is made after that commendation ceremony of that sort of thing
Even if we look at the law Thai Thai party, we are all crying when we piled up other things
I'm already deeply depressed if I live
I saw it too and I really lost it there for the first time I see there
Really come existence may come
I agree
Now and then sometimes
Come out in a dream
I still can not forget the feeling of that time
It is heavy
I can not come this way